[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now fall has
officially arrived and the change in
seasons may also mean you should make
some changes in your approach to health
management flu season is upon us and
there are a lot of considerations to
take in mind today we are joined by
primary care provider marinara of p3
medical group the sponsors of this
segment and mary thank you so much for
being here i know you have a lot of
great insight and some important things
to share with us today
i hope so so let's get right to it what
are some things that people should look
out for to recognize if they actually
have the flu or not so flu season is
here and it can be a little especially
confusing with coven 19 because a lot of
the symptoms overlap
flu typically has a very acute onset so
you feel sick quickly or you wake up
feeling sick it can include body aches
temperatures cough stuffy nose
even diarrhea like especially in
children
and what should people do if they think
that they might have the flu or are
starting to see symptoms since it can be
challenging to tell the difference i
think the best advice is to go see your
health care provider there are rapid flu
tests that can identify influenza
infection and also covid tests so that
can help differentiate the two
and then it's important to stay home so
you don't get other people ill
there are anti-viral medicines for the
flu so if we catch it quick enough we
can give you medicine that will get you
better faster and is there anything to
prioritize in that order or just the
minute you start feeling that way start
taking those steps i think the minute
you start feeling sick it's important to
start taking those steps and in terms of
prevention it's important this time to
year to just continue to eat healthy be
active get plenty of rest
eight to ten hours a night if possible
and i know a lot of people wonder this
if you start to feel sick is that too
late to go get the vaccine or get a shot
or is it still okay to do that as soon
as symptoms start to appear
no it's okay if you're feeling a little
bit ill i should mention that the best
way to help prevent the flu is to get
the vaccine it's also been shown if you
are vaccinated you are less likely to
have serious illness or end up in the
hospital so if you're having just mild
symptoms of illness you can go ahead and
get the flu shot if you're feeling
really sick or have a high temperature
then it's better to wait until you're
feeling better
and thank you so much for all this great
information it really helps to just
break it down and we're always confused
if it's the flu or if it's a cold or
something else and before we let you go
can you just talk a little bit more
about p3 health partners and the
services that you guys offer here in
nevada sure p3 is a group of primary
care offices we're affiliated with over
350 affiliate healthcare providers in
primary care and over a thousand
specialists and we're really just
focused on delivering patient centered
care
in in las vegas well thank you so much
mary for breaking this all down and all
of those helpful stills that were up on
our screen here if anyone has any
questions they can come find you and you
guys can break it all down for them
right absolutely and for more
information we'll put us still up here
there you go you can call p3 medical
group at 702-333-4700
thank you to p3 medical group for
sponsoring this segment their website is
there too we'll be right back
[Music]